girls here is marriages men parties not
particularly in that
order but Darlings we always come
vers for certain girls of refinement New
York has become too limited I quite
agree he insists that I invite you and
your daughters to London London London
London for the debutant
ball Americans they're all new money and
I'm quite sure they'll be frightful we
must just grit our teeth and think of
the bucket loads of cash here is to a
new
world shoulders back head high be
Fearless sorry sorry am Nan welcome
fresh from New York imagine a whirlwind
romance with a handsome English Lord of
course you have no interest at all in
being admired I can admire myself can't
die I pay attention to things that most
people ignore
they're like cattle rather harsh I think
they're lovely yes they are lovely but
they're also human beings Who funny and
smart girls that generally meet don't
think or talk so freely or so
passionately imagine not realizing
you're in the presence of a Duke oh is
this are you what I am light as a
feather I'm stiff as a give me one good
reason why you couldn't be a duchess I
can't possibly what actually is a
duchess
this is Guy thwart my oldest friend
you've met a man
yes she moves in such an unexpected
way have you noticed yeah I'm am
am girls are taught that if a
story isn't a love story it's a tragedy
I know my place I know my place well we
have
us
and what if this is our love
story
all goodness what a lady you are all
I've ever wanted to
be
[Music]
C